Olá pessoal todos nós estamos
acompanhando a situação das enchentes no
Rio Grande do Sul e no meio dessa
situação tão triste é incrível ver a
mobilização de tantas pessoas
trabalhando incansavelmente ajudando nos
resgates de pessoas e animais enquanto
outros estão contribuindo como podem
seja doando levantando Fundos ou
simplesmente espalhando a palavra há
diversas maneiras de ajudar os Correios
por exemplo estão disponibilizando o
envio gratuito de doações Se cada um de
nós contribuir dentro das nossas
possibilidades conseguiremos fazer uma
diferença muito significativa muitas
pessoas me pediram para divulgar um site
que está reunindo informações sobre
desaparecidos para que possamos ajudar
as famílias e amigos na busca os seus
entes queridos acessem desaparecidos
rs.com.br o link também estará na
descrição do vídeo e nos Stories vamos
juntos divulgar para que mais pessoas
possam encontrar abrigo e apoio muito
obrigado